[music playing]
NARRATOR: Outside the ruins
of Sacsayhuaman, just a mile
and a half from the
Coricancha Temple in Cusco,
are little-known entrances
to underground passageways
dating back to the Inca.
Many of the openings
have been covered up
and sealed for public
safety, but a few
still remain accessible.
In 2017, David Childress
visited the site of one
of the remaining open tunnels.
DAVID CHILDRESS: There
is a labyrinth of tunnels
beneath Cusco, and they
extend for hundreds
of miles in every direction.
And some of these
tunnels even intersect.
Over the years,
these tunnels have
been blocked off and sealed.
But you can still access
parts of this tunnel system,
such as this tunnel here,
cut through solid rock.
Local legend says
that the sun disc
was transported out of the
city through these tunnels.
There's been a lot of
speculation of where the sun
disc was taken, and
treasure hunters
have been searching for
this location for centuries.
ASHLEY COWIE:
Legends recount three
myths as to how with the sacred
golden sun disc left Cusco.
Some legends maintain that it
was taken out through a tunnel
system to Grand
Paititi, a lost Inca
village at the top
of a mountain which
the Spanish never, ever found.
Some maintain it was
taken to Sacsayhuaman,
and some maintain it was
returned to Lake Titicaca
from whence it came.
NARRATOR: Located more than
200 miles southeast of Cusco
at an elevation of over
12,500 feet above sea level,
Titicaca is the highest
navigable lake in the world
and considered sacred to
the local Andean population.
WILLIAM HENRY: In the
Incan creation myth,
their god Viracocha
emerged from Lake Titicaca.
This goes along with ancient
myths and legends that tell us
that there is an etheric
or etherial city that's
underneath Lake Titicaca.
In light of this, it makes sense
that the Incas returned their
prized golden disc to the lake.
ASHLEY COWIE: The
temple was said
to be a thing of imagination--
a thing of wonder,
until the year 2000.
In the year 2000, a team of
Italian divers and scientists
ventured to the base
of Lake Titicaca
after finding a
road of Inca stones.
They followed the road for
just less than half a mile
into the lake and
discovered a 650-
by 150-foot temple underneath
the waters of Lake Titicaca.